nature the most powerful creative force
on Earth
[Music]
I'm Chef Melissa King cooking has taken
me to incredible places wow
from TV competitions and celebrity Galas
to countries around the world
I'm heading out to places I've never
been before
seek out new experiences and to create
new dishes inspired by Nature wow this
is a
teaming up with some of the world's
greatest explorers to go further than
I've ever gone before I love how excited
you get about fungal organisms oh yeah I
have to push my craft creativity and my
cooking
this is
tasting Wild
[Music]
rainforest
they cover just six percent of our
planet but are so important
not only do they bring balance to our
environment by filtering the air we
breathe but they're home to some of the
world's most unique and important
biodiversity
including some
in my kitchen
we're here in the Olympic National
Forest
home to one of the only temperate
rainforests in the continental United
States
and I'm here to meet Karina mafuni
she's a fungal ecologist
and she studies one of my favorite
ingredients
mushrooms
foreign
meeting Karina in what's known as an old
growth forest
this one actually being a rainforest and
we're going on a hike
hey Karina hey Melissa it's so good to
meet you hi you too welcome to Olympic
National Forest this is gorgeous yeah
are you up for a hike I would love that
I'm Karina mafuni I'm a fungal ecologist
and I study the interactions between
plants and fungi and the soil systems
I love being out here in these beautiful
old growth forests it just gives me this
sense of balance and I'm so lucky to be
able to call it my office
mobile organisms are so important they
are everywhere we look
the ones that we do see are usually
mushrooms and mushrooms come in all
shapes and forms and they fulfill so
many different ecological roles they
have been here for so long much longer
than us and they provide a balance in
the ecosystem I'm so excited to learn
about Melissa and her utilization of
mushrooms in the kitchen and learn about
that perspective
so our plan is to start at Mary Ming
Falls and work our way down merryman
Creek which feeds into Lake quinoa and
we're hopefully going to find some
really cool things but you have to go
through some difficulty to get to these
places that are just so beautiful and
will hold all the little secrets that
you see around every corner
wow
it's so magical
Moss is insane
so what defines an old growth forest
so the Moss that you see draping off
these trees is one of the defining
characteristics and then it really has
to do with the age of the tree so 150
200 plus years old and they're old
they're like ancient some trees out here
are well over 500 years old and the ones
that I climb are usually up towards 200
years old
so you spend time up in these trees I
climb up to the tippy top and there's
soils on tree branches a lot of people
come to see these mats of moss that are
hanging off the trees a little magical
Fairyland but the real treasure is
actually what is under those Mossy mats
that we call Canopy soil what am I
holding here yeah so canopy soil it is a
soil and it is so rich in nutrients so
under those beautiful draping mats of
moss we actually have this organic
matter that accumulates and the trees
are growing Roots out of their branches
into those mats of moss it's an uptake
nutrients from those mats incredible
there's so much life here that's
happening beyond what we can see you
really have the coolest job in the whole
world uh you have a pretty cool job
so where do we start to hunt for
mushrooms the waterfall would be a
really great place to start because we
can follow it down the river and I think
there'll be some mushrooms that we can
find down there
mushrooms tend to Anchor a dish they
carry so much earthiness they're very
versatile as well you can cook them
fresh use them dried you can turn them
into powders and Infuse them into broths
but they add a boost of flavor to your
dishes
what is really beautiful about the
balance of these ecosystems it is the
circle of life out here so the mushrooms
are decaying this providing Habitat to
so many organisms it's beautiful it's
just a sense of rebirth happening right
here in front of us yeah
I'm that person that gets distracted
when I'm on a hike always like staring
at things on the ground
I see some Sorrel here
and some licorice Fern made tea with
this
that's a great licoricey flavor
literally it's called licorice
oh look what we have here whoa what look
at this yeah so this is a type of
bullied so the main one that you might
be familiar with is bolitis edulis which
is the porcini mushroom looks a little
bit different yeah we won't want to eat
this one but if we sample this guy you
can see the pores there behind a sponge
yeah it's spongy there are just billions
of little spores in those little tubes
oh this is cool this is gorgeous
all right let's keep going all right
I'm just excited to keep going deeper
into the forest
it's so Serene driving through the woods
everywhere you look there's something
beautiful to see
the full circle here
life but you can also see Decay
everything here seems to be working in
harmony everywhere I look
yeah this Forest that we're driving
through is so beautiful and I love the
sense of balance you get as a person
when you're standing in it all you could
feel the trees like breathing you could
feel the whole ecosystem yeah just
coming alive
I'm excited to see what you cook
it's a good partnership you find the
mushrooms I'll cook them let's get out
there and ride let's do it
you lead the way
[Music]
so this is a great place to take a look
around because we're not too far off
from the Stream
get over on the other side
yeah I thought they're so cute these are
oyster mushrooms do you make any
additional log dishes with oyster
mushrooms um I cook a lot with every
kind of mushroom I don't discriminate
neither do I love them all I'm an equal
mushroom opportunist I love that when
you see mushrooms they're just kind of
like the fruit of the fungus like an
Appleton apple tree so the actual fungal
organism is all throughout this log
breaking it down and decomposing it and
recycling those nutrients into the
forest amazing
I love mushrooms but I know that there's
moments where they're not safe to eat I
always tell people you know if in doubt
throw it out and we kind of always nerd
out and say you can eat all mushrooms
but some you'll only eat once because
there there are poisonous mushrooms
these ones are definitely safe to eat
they they are a little young but there's
some clusters up here that you know look
pretty good so how do we go in I would
kind of just saw it right there right
underneath
I like feel bad taking too many I always
leave a few behind because leaving some
behind allows those spores to continue
to drop and so you're not taking all the
reproductive structures and you're
allowing them to return that to the
ecosystem just capturing them in that
Peak moment to me as a chef is so
special and really maintain the
Integrity of that ingredient I think is
is what I enjoy doing most
I'd love to see what else we can find
all right let's keep going down along
the river yeah let's go check it out
as a chef we see mushrooms come in the
kitchen all the time but to see them
growing here in its natural habitat
there's something special about being
able to harvest your food right on a log
this whole terrain is making me very
happy and being able to see this yeah
this is another oyster mushroom likely
the same species that we saw earlier but
this has had time to mature as you can
see if we lift it up we see those gills
that are holding those fungal spores
flavor gets in there when you cook them
yeah oh it smells so good it's making me
hungry can we Harvest this one yeah it's
ready to go
[Music]
it's beautiful it's magic
nature is always the place where I find
the most inspiration in my cooking
finding mushrooms like this and being
able to really tell their story through
my dish thinking of maybe making some
sort of mushroom broth or a kanji with
this to kind of bring in some of my
roots I mean you did mention roots and
the root system so I'm thinking bringing
it back to home in my heritage
I can't wait to cook for you
go
cooking mushrooms for someone that
studies mushrooms I want to get them
right
all of the things that we've gathered
together in the past couple days I want
to incorporate those ingredients and
build the layers to this dish
kanji is the chicken noodle soup of
Asian culture it reminds me of my family
and I want Karina to understand who I am
as she tastes my food
[Music]
yesterday was incredible and just thank
you so much for teaching me about all
the fungi the way you talk about forests
is the way I talk about food yeah I'm so
curious to see what you come up with I'm
so excited to take you to this really
great spot found right in the forest and
create a dish that really shows what
this place is all about
so excited
I love the forest so much help me grab
some things
foreign
[Music]
oh this is beautiful I thought you'd
like the spot and you can go ahead and
take those mushrooms out oh so many
beautiful mushrooms I have a lot of my
favorite kinds as well as the ones that
we forged yesterday yeah I see some of
my favorites the morel chanterelles we
got the shiitakes all right I thought
it'd be great to cook a rice porridge
mushroom kanji for you yeah that sounds
delicious
start off with some aromatics onions
garlic
keep an eye on that grate some ginger
which is really the base of this dish
toss the rice in stir that in yeah toast
that up it's like making a risotto yeah
we're doing a Chinese version of that
and I made this mushroom broth with all
the stems
with some kombu and just slow cook that
down
this is the base of our kanji I'm gonna
cut some mushrooms each with their own
personality
these are some of the oysters we had
from yesterday oh yeah we have to cook
these up gotta cut them up it's so cool
so I'm gonna saute these mushrooms next
throwing them all together to build a
harmonious dish each mushroom has its
own unique flavor and I love
caramelizing them getting a beautiful
sear on it it really brings out the
flavor and kind of deepens them
when it comes to making kanji at the end
of the day it's about finding the
balance between the softness of the rice
and then the textures from the garnishes
again it's about out that Harmony it's
about that balance
because we're close to the coast here
I've decided to put some dull seaweed
as a garnish all these beautiful
caramelized mushrooms are going to go
right on top these are some beautiful
little herbs we forage together from the
sorrel I wanted it to just feel like the
forest like a forest in a bowl yeah
final touches some fried shallots for
some texture just add a little Crunch
and crispiness some green onions to add
a little kick
use your mushroom kanji hope it does
Your Love Of Mushrooms Justice it's
beautiful
all right
do you Stir It Up sure okay get them in
there
that's so good that's so good
I do eat mushrooms and cook with them a
lot but I haven't eaten them in this
manner and from such a talented Chef so
thank you
the flavors they just they evolve in my
mouth kind of like the the forest that
has evolved around us over millions of
years it's like every little bite has a
little secret just kind of every corner
and the forest that you turn yeah I'm
gonna have to toast you to mushrooms I'm
gonna have to toast you to cooking chef
thank you thank you
thank you pleased to explore and cook
you can't help but be energized here
I'm taking away a deeper appreciation
for mushrooms and the balance they
provide and I'm looking forward to
taking that all back to the kitchen
[Music]